i opening impact of digital devices
nearly 60% of Americans are in front of
some type of screen for five hours or
more a day 65 percent of us report
symptoms of eyestrain dr. Christopher
Starr is an ophthalmologist at Weill
Cornell Medical Center welcome back
thank you thanks for having me
what is staring at the screen doing to
our eyes well it's doing a lot of things
actually we all sit in front of
computers for as you said many hours a
day and we do a few things when we're
staring at the computer one we tend to
blink less so the typical blink rate is
about 15 to 20 blinks per minute when
you're staring at a computer and you're
focusing out of this computer we tend to
blink it the blink rate decreases by
about 50 percent and when you're not
blinking the eyes tend to dry out if
tears evaporated you get dry spots that
can cause fatigue it can cause dryness
irritation redness tearing even as the
day goes on and it can also contribute
to eye strain we didn't got the 20-20-20
rule we have the 2012 there are a lot of
ways to prevent all of these things
20-20-20 rule means every 20 minutes
take a break from your computer look
away from the computer at something
that's 20 feet away or further for 20
seconds or more and it actually is good
advice also to at during those breaks to
sort of stand up stretch the arms the
legs now get the blood flowing if your
eyes are feeling really dry put a
lubricant in to lubricate the eyes and
remember to blink and squeeze them any
kind of special glasses you should wear
there are some special glasses for
people above 40 I'm one of those people
when the near vision starts to go you're
focusing at this fixed distance which is
pretty close to your eyes for all those
hours during the day you can get
computer glasses to help alleviate some
of that strain also there's blue light
that's emitted from computers and some
people think that the blue light can
cause fatigue and strain and there might
be some long-term damaging effects of
blue light so you can get yellow tinted
glasses which block some of that blue
light well it's still kind of early
there is evidence that ultraviolet light
can cause damage to the retina can cause
cataracts and interestingly blue light
as far as frequency goes and energy is
not so far removed from ultraviolet
light so very possibly years and years
and years
of excessive blue light might cause some
damage that really does happen to your
eye at 40 ah yeah yeah my vision was one
way I swear to you but when I turned 40
it's called a sudden had to go like that
the arm 10 is not long enough sometimes
it's called presbyopia it happens to
everyone where you want is where you get
to a little classy then you the reading
glasses come in and there are some other
things surgically that can be done as
well but it happens to everybody it's a
fact of life it's a great thing isn't
yeah it's a great thing